welcome back y'all Ken and Thompson is
here with us our next guest is a Grammy
winning artist who is one of dance hall
and reg's most prolific and successful
musicians ever his latest single is
called dim time de featuring Manuel
teriso listen now wherever you get your
music everybody say hello to Shawn
[Applause]
[Music]
Paul
[Applause]
[Music]
hello hello I like all your bling thank
you yes czy like I work hard for this um
have yall y'all met right you know each
other yeah yeah just now I was on
Saturday Night Live a while back I don't
know if you're sure that if you were
there that day but I was there that day
but we didn't get a chance to meet we
don't get a chance to meet every sing
time yeah now I've been a big fan for a
long time salute man same same so wait
your stage name is Shand der Paul now is
that what what is that from Shawn Paul
is my name my my you know my name is
Sean hyen Paul but uh there's a famous
cricketer in the Caribbean and his name
is sha deal that's his last name and it
sounded so much like my own yeah there
he is yeah and he's from Guyana and um a
lot of people uh came at me because I
first said he's from Trinidad and I I
made a mistake excuse me yeah but um you
know it was a friend of mine who was
freestyling and he I was going next on
the mic like doing doing you know
freestyling and he was like yo Shan
theal and he get and everybody laughed
and they were like yo that's the
cricketer's name but it kind of stuck on
me as a nickname around the studio and I
started to say it in songs and um just
yeah I found this incredible too so you
grew up around a lot of country music
Jamaica we we love all kind of different
music you know and so so uh yeah we have
a lot of people who are fans of of
country music I think it reminds us of
Reggae it tells a story M you know and
it's that type of music um so yeah Kenny
Rogers and Willie Nelson Kenny Rogers
will I love this I knew Willie Nelson
was coming up Willie Nelson was coming
in there yeah
jamaan he's a lifestyle yeah he's he's
he's honorary Jamaica right yeah or or
we're honorary listen listeners
why he's brilliant but yeah top of he
smokes a lot of
wheat I went on his bus once and I was
like hey and then I walked off a
different human yeah we have similar um
you know what you call and interest
interests yeah Love Languages if you
will yeah so wait so your new single is
called dim time day got okay dim time
day yeah what does that mean it means
back in the day them time there those
times there so basically um you know a
lot of people kind of remember my career
from about 20 years ago and um you know
Manuel he's a lot younger than me and he
was like yo uh back in those days was
awesome and I want to do a song like
that with you and he came to the studio
and he started writing and he's like
what do you want to call it and I said
since it's so you know reminiscent of of
them time there let's call it them time
there he loved it I've been trying to
bridge the gap between regon and
danceall music or reg music because
we're such close in proximity to you
know to uh Puerto Rico and uh Dominican
Republic Cuba but we don't speak the
language and so we do speak music though
that's what so M yeah connection man
music is magical like that I love when
you go to a show and you look around
that's my favorite part of like getting
on stage and I look at the audience I'm
like where would all of us be in the
same room like you know what I'm saying
other than this moment like you just
happen to like these songs you happen to
like this Vibe like I love that about
music that never gets old gets us
together it gets through gets us through
some crazy times like uh my mom was
telling me a story about one of your
songs and she was like she was doing
some very mundane stuff one day yeah
know sweeping floors and that kind of
stuff yeah and a lot of people was
helping her out and she started singing
A Moment Like This are you serious yeah
cuz so cuz it was kind of funny cuz
nobody wants to wait their whole life to
to do that right so your mom is funny so
she she said I must big you up and and
it helped everybody get through it they
all was singing it and motivated them to
she has incredible taste Sean she does
right she
does all right we've got a performance
of the new single D time de from Shawn
Paul featuring Manuel teriso coming up
later you can download the song Now
wherever you get your
[Music]
[Applause]
music thank you guys
y'all have a great night I'm going
home